so that song is about kind of some of
the the hate you received over the years
yes it's a little bit about yeah I have
deeply unpopular I am but it doesn't
matter because my wife loves me
oh they asked me to pay off for her poor
no you have turned it to a strength that
wait people are kind of rude about you
yeah I mess around don't I I met her
online on Twitter abusing myself before
were people yeah I've you know you guys
do you follow him on Twitter no you
should be very good examples of James's
tweet because we all take a moment to
remember just how terrible James Blunt
was no need I have a new album coming
soon go to the sitter
what would he even tweet about boning
your mom
this one a James Blunt actually pure
Calabria would've died they said Hitler
I'm guessing this is not good beautiful
little many days what never hurt anybody
depends where I put it this is rumored I
just irony to the DJ's but when I'm
menstruating useful feedback hour passes
on to my marketing Dave loves space
fully aggravates me then sit on
something else where nor near if you'd
like to see even more stuff like that
that hit subscribe hotel
free world but I know what I do in that
situation